thanks Peter hello everybody and welcome
to accelerate genomics discovery with
Esther in the cloud as Peter said my
name is Yuri and I am the asteroid
project owner however before we get
started with the webinar I would want to
for you to take this poll this can tell
me what your interests are in this
webinar and I can tailor the message in
the webinar based on the results here to
make sure that you get the most benefit
out of this webinar and this is an
interactive poll so just click on your
screen in a couple of more seconds when
everybody finishes answering I will
share the results with everybody and
these are anonymized results so we'll
just see the percentage for the options
that I'd picked great the major interest
here is why should you use a straight
nail in the cloud and also what
technologies you should know about if
you can either be doing work in the
cloud and the third topic of interest is
you're just here to learn about cloud
yes data and how to use clouds so this
webinar will cover some basics like
introduction to SRA and why SRA was
moved to the cloud the benefits that
you'll get from working in the cloud and
of course the tools we've made available
so far I'll cover two case studies that
highlight Cloud usage and provide you
some information and links of where you
can go to get started with using cloud
resources and at the end we'll hold the
Q&A session so for those of you who
don't know about no sorry we are the
sequence read archive from NCBI we
started in 2008 and our primary mission
is to store and distribute
next-generation sequencing data we are
accept all types of samples and all
types of data from all types of 16
platforms and this day is used in a
variety of different ways things from
band from attics mother's development to
detection of novel genes or microbial
viral species even so why do
we move to the cloud why did we do it 12
years after we started well s rate has
been growing exponentially a
year-to-year and at this point we are
over 14 petabytes of data and we have
over 25 petabytes of user submitted
files that we can share with the
scientific community and this is a lot
of data and moving it from Bethesda and
Maryland to anywhere in the world is a
very technically complex task and also a
very time-consuming task some of our
users need to wait weeks or months to
just download data before they can even
do any computational analysis on it and
of course sometimes they just convert
that some of the data they downloaded is
not useful and they need to download
more so this is a really big barrier to
doing quick analysis on the data that's
available and because there's such great
benefit from it we want to speed this up
for the scientific community and so we
went ahead and moved all 14 petabytes of
sra archival data into the cloud and
from there you can get faster access to
this data you have powerful computer
resources in the cloud that are
available to you on demand you can
easily expand the storage that you are
using in the cloud so you're never
waiting to get more storage and the
cloud can be a great collaboration
platform you can have your collaborators
who might be in different parts of the
world login into the same system run the
same pipelines and look at the same
results whenever they want you don't
need to share those results individually
anymore since everybody can log in into
the same server what we've done so far
is we mentioned is we moved all of the
SRA our color format to the cloud and
that's available now we also started
moving the user submitted files which is
roughly 25 petabytes more of data and
this is a new feature from SRA so using
our careful format you can get to the
files that we received from the
submitters and that's we're always
trying to be more efficient
and we want you to be more efficient in
the cloud we started producing context
ourselves for now we only produce
context for metagenomic data sites but
we will certainly be branching out to
RNA seek genomic data sets and other
tape of this as time goes on now in
order to access all of this data we've
updated our API which is the SRA toolkit
to work in the cloud as well so instead
of downloading data from Bethesda you
will be accessing the data in our cloud
buckets if you're working in the cloud
so this will speed up file access
another new feature is we've made
available our metadata in native cloud
architecture and for now this is just
Google's bigquery product but this was a
very popular feature and we will be
moving all of this also to Amazon's
Athena now that we've received positive
feedback from a scientific community for
this so the two case studies I wanted to
highlight was the NCBI virus discovery
code on because I think it's a good
example of cloud computing and the
benefits of cloud computing and our
interaction with that cloud customer who
wanted to do things natively in the
cloud so the antivirus discovery
codeathon
was started with the assumption that
there's a lot of viral data available in
Medici Network datasets and so we
brought several teams together and the
goal was to build some analysis and
processing pipelines for this dataset
now I won't be going into the details of
the actual code on or the results of it
but if you are interested to read about
it there's a publication link you can
follow but what I want to talk about is
that a pre-computation that had to
happen before we can hold the code on
the assumption was that everybody would
be working on context and not raw data
so what sorry did was we took 140,000
runs of management data sets that were
seven gigabytes or smaller in size
and we built context from this and so
this was either her de novo assembly or
guided assemblies and we ended up
building 3.9 billion context of all of
this data and in order to accomplish
this we actually had to take a two step
approach in our computation the first
one was using fire fire nodes or like
five friend servers
machines that were only two cores on
eight gigabytes in memory these are very
small machines I think some of our cell
phones are more powerful than this at
this time and of course we had to use
larger machines for the bigger files and
for those we used a hundred machines but
these had 96 cores and 300 gigabytes of
RAM so these are big powerful machines
well why didn't we do it in the cloud
well it only took us a couple of weeks
to do this in the cloud but we knew that
if we try to do this internally at NCBI
on our high computing cluster it would
take us several months to do this so you
can see the bar change there from a
couple weeks to several months of
computing all of these contexts and
that's because sra is not the only
resource at NCBI we share that try
computing cluster with other resources
and of course we would be queued up for
all of our computational needs and this
is something that some of you might have
faced before as well as your
universities error and the cloud all of
the computer is what we want and it's at
our fingertips here so what we learned
from this experience is if you want to
get started faster in the cloud
collaborations help with this so if
you're collaborating with my firm
additions or programmers who are
familiar with cloud architecture they
can help you get started faster but you
can certainly do this on your own but if
you're going to do this on your own make
sure you start working in a small scale
first this will help you learn the
different technologies and if you're
using known datasets that are small and
quick to compute on you know what the
results should be and as you get more
comfortable with technology
expand slowly premature scaling to a
hundred or several hundred machines can
lead to a large problem and you won't
know where to debug the problem so it's
very important to scale slowly so you
can understand what's happening and if
you run into any issues you can
understand where to look for the
problems well if you want to know what
technologies we used in our computation
approach that was kubernetes docker
images for the tools there were some
scripting using Python and bash and
snake make so these are not only cloud
technologies available they obviously
have competitors and so as you're
looking into cloud technologies some of
those other technologies might be a
better fit for you than the ones we used
and we try to make our compute cheaper
so we used preemptable or spot instances
depending on which cloud vendor you and
I use those are cheaper options for
compute that you should take a look into
on a notes section of this presentation
I added links the different resources
that you should check out so after the
webinar feel free to look at those to
get more information about any of these
different topics the community use case
that I wanted to highlight was from a
researcher who was interested in a
volition area relationship of microbial
communities in marine environments so
they were looking at marine melanoma
datasets what they really wanted to do
was build up a automatic pipeline to
look through a three data and the
pipeline would run in the cloud they
needed to be able to search for these
datasets quickly and efficiently and I
wanted to be able to fine tune their
search parameters for these datasets
very easily and their other need was to
be able to actually know what the
microbial communities are within the s3
datasets so for this we thought that
bigquery or Amazon's Athena products
would be
good fit so we started doing our testing
in bigquery and what we started out with
is putting SRA metadata there so we put
sample information so where the sample
was collected from like what depths all
of this metadata that users provide for
us we also provided sequencing
information of how the sample were
sequenced in terms of what platforms
were used and also some basic statistic
information such as the number of bytes
or the number of reads a number of bases
available in this data set so this
allowed the user to select high quality
data sets from a particular sequencing
platform they were interested in or if
they wanted the run to be of a certain
size now for their second need which was
to know that economic content of the
actual asuri run for that we had to make
the results from the s rate economic
analysis to available in bigquery now we
haven't released this publicly yet as we
were still going through testing with a
small user group but we will be
releasing this soon and all of this
functionality will be copied to Amazon's
athina as well given a little bit more
time so with this day is that they can
actually identify what microbial
communities are available in a
particular run so that they can fine
tune their search parameters even more
and since this information is available
very quickly from bigquery what they can
do is take the search based on sample
and sequencing information take the
search results from they fix anomic
content and combine them I can take the
intersection of them thereby getting a
very small data set of runs that they
can run more expensive computational
analysis on so getting started is
actually fairly easy what you will get
out of this will be very customized
filtering for data size that you want to
analyze it will obviously have very
powerful compute available to you and
all you need is a laptop to login into
the cloud architecture if you're worried
about costs both Amazon and Google have
three tiers available where you can
start playing around with this new
technology and moving your analysis of
pipelines or processes into the cloud
and if you're working with small
datasets on small machines all of this
can be free for you so definitely don't
be worried about it well if you need to
actually get the data out of a cloud
that's called egress and you should
really only be aggressing things that
are the results of your analysis that is
much smaller in size than actual raw
data or any kind of middle files that
you might generate between different
tools if you're ready to get started
there we've made videos available on how
to start a cloud instance in both Amazon
and Google so you can check out our
YouTube channel for that we've also
provided help documentation for all of
this information in terms of gangue
started with computing and some example
queries for bigquery so you can find all
of this in our help documentation now
that I introduced the tools we've made
available to you we're always looking
for more feedback from the scientific
community so please reach out to us tell
us if something works for you or
something doesn't work for you that's
even more important because if we know
what's not working we can try and fix it
and make the tools better for you so the
more feedback we get on anything either
for SRA or NCBI will pay dividends
feedback as we can improve our resources
to meet your needs so if you want to
just continue following NCBI and what
we're releasing into the cloud you can
follow the NCBI insights blog where
we'll be posting more information about
upcoming in functionality we also send
direct messages and twitter and you can
follow NCBI for that authorities also
registered with Amazon open data
registry so you
find us are there as well and that's
about its I can now open the floor to
any questions that you guys might have
you know how uriens is Peter so we have
some questions in the chat pod and then
I think I'm gonna ask you you were gonna
do a you were thinking about doing a
demonstration of bigquery if we have
time I think we can do that because
somebody did ask that one okay but the
first there's some other simpler ones
somebody asked a question about
sequences that are submitted to ena to
the European nucleotide archive so I I
think we basically get those sequences
into s alright and they would wind up on
the cloud is that not true that's true
since SRA is part of the IND see
everything that is part of SRA is also
available in the cloud as well okay
another one that's kind of similar in
spirit
they were asking whether SRA is mirrored
or split between 80 west and GCP and I
believe it's mirrored in both places so
you can get it on either platform is
that correct that's correct
it's a perfectly mirrored so you can
depending on your needs you can use
either platform and one other simpler
one although it's kind of a sensitive
topic because we don't like to talk
directly about the cost that we've
experienced from the government point of
view but can you comment on the compute
cost associated with the content
creation so that is definitely a
difficult topic to answer I don't know
there a specific number but it was
probably several thousands of dollars or
tens of thousands of dollars in terms of
communication I don't know how that
would relate to anybody else's expenses
but considering the amount of data we
processed and how fast we processor
assists that I think it was a good
expense for us okay thanks Yuri and so I
guess the other question was somebody
was asking about using bigquery and the
metadata and so we had a you had a demo
that you could do with that that might
be useful to do if you have time sure I
can do that so of course the easiest way
to find bigquery is just to do a Google
search for it
what's your here um if you don't have a
Google account you probably will need to
create it right from here it's very
simple you can go to the console page so
this is the web interface that Google
provided for their service for bigquery
and I think it's fairly intuitive to use
so you can see your cue query history
the safe queries you've run and some
other options on here now in order to
connect to the SRA Kingdom in Vickrey I
find it easier to in our project so I
lump in my project here I want to go to
the add data section here click on it
and there's a BIM project selection so
our project is called NIH - oh sorry -
data store so I type that in and just
click on the pin button let's try that
again I might have had a typo there okay
well I might be typing something there
but uh once you add the data store you
can take a look at what's available
there but I'll use one of our my saved
queries here to find some runs for you
so I can just click on open query and
click run so in order to use my query
you will need to learn SQL or sequel and
we have some example queries available
on documentation pages so you can copy
those to get started there's a lot of
very useful tutorials online for using
sequel and learning sequel but to get
started it's not very hard so I have a
more complex query here but as you saw I
ran the query the results came back in
seconds and you can see that
I selected different type of runs either
from ddbj for this one this one was
submitted to s array and I displayed
some columns that might be useful to me
such as the number of spots used in the
analysis and percent of unidentified
reads so between the performance of the
query and the ability to write your own
queries and customize the results this
is a very useful tool for pipeline
developers and or even if you just want
to get access to this data very quickly
you can use the web interface to search
for your data sets so I think it's a
very powerful tool that can be very
beneficial Thank You Yuri we got a
couple of more questions actually
there's probably three of them that or
four of them actually that we should
probably address someone asks is there
an SRA docker container store for SRA
toolkit and other apps so SRA will be
releasing a docker image with a straight
toolkit it's you know our roadmap to put
that on Tucker hub so that will
definitely be coming soon NCBI has a
docker hub account where you can look
for other products that ncbi supports in
Dockers so please check out NCBI at the
docker hub another question that's sort
of a general one that's probably useful
to address it has to do with what data
are publicly accessible and I think it's
probably worth talking about the
difference between the controlled-access
data and the data that's not controlled
access and what one lab you did to get
to those things right so we have public
data that's available right now for
controlled access human data you would
need to get access to that data set
through even gap first but that data is
available in the cloud as well so if you
have access to to this as through TP gap
you can certainly access them in the
cloud as well okay Thank You Yuri
another question
do with the context and I think you
mentioned that they should be available
before too long how soon do you think
they will be available so the context
for Milo genomic data sets are available
now and I think I added the link to the
documentation for them into the
presentation but if it's not there I'll
make sure to send out the link to the
documentation for them after that
presentation and the context are
available in both Amazon and GCP so the
other question is again was it that the
compute cost personally but I think you
addressed that when you talked about the
cost that we incurred when we were doing
those contexts yeah unfortunately I
can't answer the question of cost per
assembly but I can certainly get in
touch let's go over ask that question to
talk to you more offline about that job
yeah that's a good idea so you can sort
my contact you can write into the
webinars address if you want to webinar
is at NCBI
NLM znh gov and somewhere else so asks
can you throw an example of actually
doing an assembly in the cloud for
particular SRR so assemble in the cloud
is not any different than running
assembly at your local server you use
the same tools as you would there as
well and the only difference is that
instead of running it at a local server
that you have available to you or your
desktop you're doing it on a server
that's located in the cloud but the
actual process itself is not any
different so in this case I would just
be calling up an assembler and providing
data to it I don't have a demo available
right this minute but I'm sure that
that's where I can make a demo of that
and share it okay another question which
is I think you addressed this and in
some ways this webinar was about this
very topic but it's probably worth just
reiterating so the question is what is
the advantages to use easy to instances
that
using my own computer which is basically
using the cloud instead of this person's
own computer so maybe there's like just
a couple of points - oh sure
so if you're downloading data using this
rate to look at it usually pulls data
from our servers and but that's also the
world everybody around the world is
accessing the data as well so you're
obviously competing for resources there
in the cloud it scales
basically automatically you you get
faster access to the data there as well
also if you need more powerful compute
that's not available locally to you you
have those machines available in the
cloud as well so as I said we had those
bigger machines that had 96 cores and
300 concubines of RAM so those might be
hard to get locally for you but they are
available to you easily on the cloud
architecture so those are kind of the
benefits of doing that where you get
faster access to data far more powerful
compute so if you move your pipelines
and processes there you can see a
speed-up in the overall analysis thanks
URI that was a good question and that's
a good way to you know sort of seal
things we're talking about this the main
advantage of doing this you know we
mentioned the access to the context
which are now available is is it easy
for you to show us how to get access to
them sure
so here I'm just going to the virus
discovery github page and there's readme
on how to get access and we provide
instructions of how you would want to
download the context so this case if you
are somewhere in the cloud either Google
or Amazon you can run either this AWS s3
copy command and download the contact
file to your processing area in Amazon
there's a similar command with GSU tools
for google you can even run a W gif
command from a cloud instance running an
Amazon to download the data so that's
all it really takes is running this one
command to download one of the contexts
FASTA files
okay that's great I don't see any more
questions I think we're just about done
with somebody says they have one more
just a second okay let's see what this
one is so this is an interesting one we
might not be able to address this
directly but this is about the data from
G is a ID and how does that does that
data get reflected in SRA this is
particularly relevant for the
coronavirus data right unfortunately I
don't believe we have that data
available at SRA
we are certainly exploring options on
how to get access to that data so it
would be a publicly available
okay URI I think that's all the
questions we have and if there's any
that we didn't get to we'll be sure to
address them in the document that we're
going to produce so I think we can go
ahead and wrap this up thanks everybody
for coming and thank you URI thank you